and as you may have seen just a moment
ago I'm joined Now by Graham Stewart
who's the minister of climate a very
good morning thanks so much for coming
in so one story really dominating the
front pages of the papers there those
warnings from National Grid
do we have to accept that we need to
brace ourselves for blackouts this
winter well the National Grid published
its report as it does every year
yesterday and it looks at various
scenarios and you know including the
more extreme ones
um the good news Adam is that they've
said on their sort of central scenarios
that we're in a pretty good position
compared to our uh other European
neighbors we're not dependent on Russian
gas we have nearly nearly half our gas
is produced domestically we have solid
and reliable suppliers like Norway and
we have the second largest LNG liquid
national natural gas
infrastructure in Europe so we're
actually well positioned but given uh
the illegal and appalling war in Ukraine
given the pressures on our European
neighbors with whom we have
interconnectors and interdependence then
they've looked at you know all options
they've said it's very unlikely that
there would be blackouts but we as a
government and working with off German
National Grid we do everything possible
to plan for all eventualities and uh you
know given the war in Ukraine and
Russia's appalling aggression
um this winter
is has higher risks than we've seen in
previous Winters but I wouldn't want to
extend it more than that so was Liz Ross
a bit rash in saying there'd be no
rationing when she was campaigning for
the leadership well what she said is
that that you you
um you can't I mean I thought you were
going to refer to the blackouts question
and which is you can't guarantee what's
going to happen in terms of the nature
of our energy Supply it's different from
many of our European neighbors because
we've got such a set of diverse supplies
we're not in the same position as being
reliant on storage without which we
wouldn't be able to get through and
therefore you that's why you know when
you look at things like Energy
Efficiency and the messages to the
public that's why off gem are talking to
uh big users commercial users as well as
as I think your story mentioned those
with uh uh with the technology scenario
we could be looking at rationing planned
blackouts we could be looking at
rationing
um we don't expect that to occur that's
not our expectation at all
um but we you know you've seen all sorts
of things happening in uh recent weeks
and uh you know we we plan for all
eventualities and the public should be
confident that we have a very strong and
diverse uh Supply that we've taken all
the steps to look after our needs for
this winter and we're also of course
um uh taking and the Prime Minister has
been you know really focused on this is
making sure that we uh we aren't in a
vulnerable position ever again in future
okay so we can't rule out rationing
should we should we all be trying to use
less energy
uh we're not uh sending that out as a
message there's all of us have bills of
course and the bills have gone up it's
been I mean one of the biggest steps and
one of the boldest um and most effective
steps taken by the Prime Minister has
been to step in and protect families and
businesses from the rising costs
um uh you know in family's case for the
next two years and so whereas uh you
know there was talk that some people
might be paying more than six thousand
pounds for their energy the average
family because what we're doing is
intervening at the sort of unit of
energy uh point the average family on
average use would not expect to be
paying more than two and a half thousand
pounds a year so that's that's meant
that uh jobs as well as family finances
are protected yeah so the energy support
scheme obviously welcomed by a lot of
people but why aren't you advising
people to use less energy isn't that
eminently sensible I mean we read this
week that the business secretary signed
off on a public information campaign to
encourage people to save energy but that
was rejected by number 10. but we're I
mean the way we make
um policy is where it's all we look at
all the options
um including you know whether would that
be rejected but the nature of our Energy
System is different so if you if you I
there are good reasons why people might
want to uh you know take a shower on the
bath if because it cuts their energy
bills
um most of the time except in Peak
because of the nature of our Energy
System it doesn't make any difference to
our energy security that's different in
Germany it's different in Holland I'm
not talking about Europe I'm talking
about this country exactly and we
understand tell me if I'm wrong that the
business secretary signed off on a
public information campaign to encourage
people to save energy which would also
mean they'd save money of course as well
wouldn't it but it was rejected by
number 10. can you confirm that I I
don't I don't I don't recognize that
we're in an iterative process of policy
development and ideas and we come to a
conclusion so the idea you know there
are some highly developed Campaign which
we were on you know the climate and
energy Minister passionately devoted to
and number 10 I don't recognize that I
don't think that's the the way it was
and uh you know it it's it's about
getting the right messaging from the
right partners and you'll find through
um off-cham and through the gov dot UK
website there is advice for people on
how they can save save on their um
Family finances but the last thing you
want to do is tell someone you know
switch things off for the national need
when it makes no difference
um to the National Security position so
that's why you've got to you've got to
look at these things in the round and
make sure you get the messages in the
most nuanced and subtle and effective
way possible so even though we get
warnings from the National Grid all be
in the worst case scenario that there
could be planned blackouts you still
don't think it's worth telling people
how they might be able to save energy
which incidentally will save the money
too no you're absolutely right Anna the
the when what they've tried to get is if
there were such a scenario it would come
at a very sharp point so the fact that
somebody hadn't
um you know had reduced their energy
usage a week before or even a day before
you get to a peak wouldn't really make
any difference to the to the security of
Supply so that's that's why it I know it
looks like why it's obvious why don't
you go out and tell everyone to use less
energy I we think that we've got a
pretty um we've got a diverse strong
Supply and in all the central scenarios
um we're going to be fine but we plan
for everything and we want to get that
you know I'm really grateful for you
focusing on it today to get those
messages out to people you talk about a
diverse strong Supply the UK is opening
a new licensing round for companies to
explore oil and gas in the North Sea
isn't that that though at odds with the
government's policy on Net Zero your
climate Minister what do you think no
absolutely not I mean what you have to
remember is we we've led the world on
reducing emissions we're the first major
country to legislate for Net Zero we
have five-year carbon budgets if you
look at gas and oil we will be burning
gas I'll be at a quarter of what we do
today in 2050. under our Net Zero um
program and what you'll also see is that
UK gas has a much lower emissions
package around it than does imported gas
so the more that we can produce
ourselves the lower will be our
emissions for the amount of energy which
we burn which is strictly limited by the
framework set by the climate change act
even though the International
um intergovernmental panel on climate
change the ipcc and the iea the
International Energy agency both say
there should be no new fossil fuel
project if we have a chance of meeting
that one point well we're on a
transition and it you know it is I think
you know on the projection that I've
seen we should be on around one to one
our investment at the moment by 2030 it
should be more Mark Carney was saying
yesterday it should be four to one but
it's not four to zero we it's a
transition and we need oil and gas
um to you know keep the lights on we're
we're I mean I think it's around 70 of
our energy needs in the UK are currently
based on fossil fuel
um you've got to manage that transition
and it could be said that uh getting and
making sure that we have that orderly
transition driven by investment in
Renewables and which of course we're a
world leader and and all your viewers
can be extremely proud it's important
that we get that balance right and it's
that balance which is striking today and
of course by producing our own gas we've
got more jobs and we have more tax for
the UK and we make ourselves left less
dependent on regime some of which spend
the money to buy missiles to threaten us
one of your father Minister Steve Baker
said the UK can't afford Net Zero
pledges in the short term so do you
agree with that
um we are committed to uh Net Zero it's
a matter of law
um and uh of course we can we there are
huge economic opportunities in Net Zero
you look at the jobs that have already
come yeah from offshore wind we've now
just changed the rules around onshore my
job from the Prime Minister when I I
said to her when she appointed me to
this role what do you want me to do
accelerate yourself accelerate um
offshore win let's shorten the time it
takes to get a new
um uh Wind Farm up let's make sure that
we you know we do it right but it can't
be right that uh the length of the
permissioning time from kind of starting
a project of having it first turning its
blades has gone up as much as it has so
we're across the piece we're looking to
accelerate it and we got nuclear and
there was an announcement from Jacob
Reese smog around Fusion which is
phenomenal potential technology and
we're hoping to be the first country in
the world to have a prototype Fusion
plant you know putting energy into the
Grid in 2040. why was King Charles
advised by the government not to go to
cop27
where King's Charles decides to go I
think is very much up to him
but was he advised by I I don't know I
I'm not your climate Minister you don't
I don't know about that but um would you
like him to go he's worked in this field
for I I don't think I don't think it's
for ministers on even on a as esteemed a
program as yours Anna uh to be uh
telling the king what he should or
shouldn't do
um but I mean his his role of course
moving from Prince of Wales to King has
changed and um you know we uh I'm very
much looking forward to attending charm
as I will be as will my secretary of
state and carrying on the great work
that we did in cop26 because Alex Sharma
is worth ending on a super positive of
this interview with just 30 of global
GDP was covered by Net Zero pledges when
he took up his presidency it's now 90
that's British leadership globally and
it's uh you know I think we can be
inordinately proud of it and we're
following up that work at cop26 in charm
you say an end on positive I'm just
going to bring one negative in I'm
afraid you wouldn't be a journalist if
you didn't culture Dean Doris has
accused the government of lurching to
the ride she's warning your party facing
a Wipeout if at the next election if you
don't change course what do you make of
that well I I you know we've just done
with this energy support package one of
the biggest interventions by the state
to help people who've ever seen the
commitment to Net Zero is there I don't
recognize I mean you know I know how
bruising it can be when you leave
government
um and uh you know I think what what I
what I did and I would certainly advise
Nadine too the best thing to do is just
to you know settle down a little while
and uh and and let the new team get on
with the job and that's what we're doing
we're doing it in a way which is putting
the long-term interest of the British
people first and in the meantime is
intervening uh significantly to protect
families and businesses across the
country from what is a very troubled
global environment